our dialogue today focused
mainly on youth
youth, which has been one of the subjects on
which we have concentrated quite a bit of
time and this live and the implementation
of our partnership for youth
between the union  and tunisia that help
launched last december we
recalled this exceptional process of
democratic transition of tunisia
since 2011
we addressed the socio-
economic challenges of tunisia and the measures
that we wish to take together
to relaunch the future we
also  discussed
employability participation in public life
we ​​agreed on the
need to develop and promote
more dialogue between youth in
the european union and youth in
tunisia within the framework of this last
objective the union  european union and
tunisia signed today before
our meeting an agreement on
tunisia's accession to the
creative europe program this will be
an additional opportunity
promote dialogue and exchanges
between our peoples we must create
real prospects for today's generation,
with
jobs, good jobs as a result, and for their good jobs,
we will have to focus on
the economy and this title  it is a good
thing that there is now a new
impetus given to the negotiations with a view to
concluding the free trade agreement
the partnership for youth reflects
our common desire to give
Tunisian youth a
special place in our
future cooperation as the partnership for
growth aims to support
the efforts of the Tunisian government
in its economic transition